viu obrigado a todos os presentes
obrigados a todos que estão é no brasil
e fora do brasil assistindo a gente
protex é uma honra estar aqui com vocês
e espero trazer um assunto que possa ser
é relevante para a vida de vocês é
primeira coisa eu queria perguntar pra
vocês uma pergunta simples porque na
verdade todos aqui eu tenho certeza que
utilizam os meios novas tecnologias de
comunicação de informação e tudo mais
quem que utiliza um tablet utiliza um
celular um smartphone é é utilizar um
computador para obter informações e para
se comunicar no dia a dia eu tô vendo
aqui todos é é levantar a mão tem
certeza que você está em casa também
está acessando uma nova tecnologia então
já está respondido à pergunta a questão
que eu venho discutir com vocês central
é essa tecnologia está sendo usada de
que forma por vocês como que ela está
contribuindo para a sua vida
vocês acham que é importante
carinhas que dizendo que sim todo mundo
afirmou
as possibilidades sim ela ajuda em que
em uma palavra aqui só tem 15 minutos à
comunicação e informação exibição
pessoal adora se exibir nos meios de
comunicação é que mais gente
praticidade eu sou de uma época que
assim pra falar com a minha família que
estava bem quando estava estudando no
rio de janeiro era uma maratona gente
existe um tal de de que telefone azul
assim tinha uma ficha prateados e nunca
ouviu falar isso tem que ver esse museu
que botar a ficha de de pra você poder
falar era cara essa ficha e era difícil
falar a maioria das casas não tinha
telefone celular uma coisa que não
existia praticamente então a comunicação
realmente é muito difícil
a exibição que o nobre amigo aí ele
falou aqui uma coisa que está vendo cada
vez mais né
tem algumas pessoas que são mestres em
utilizar a meio de comunicação para
exibição e que mal há nisso né
cada 1 exibe que é seu está no seu
direito agora como a colega falou aqui
comunicação é tem gente que usa como
entretenimento também né pra se divertir
né como uma forma de diversão é é meu
filho quando chego em casa kata meu
smartphone na hora entra nós já temos
aplicativos que baixou de ficar
brincando tem uns de carrinho tem outros
não sei o que é mas acho que todo mundo
é que de uma forma ou de outra usa esses
meios de comunicação usa essas novas
tecnologias
a questão que eu venho debater com vocês
é elas melhoraram a sua vida pra vocês
elas melhoraram a vida de vocês carinhas
positivas soffiatti também de alguma
forma de torre vem com certeza
então a questão é que eu venho
discutindo vem debatendo com as pessoas
é que eu como médico que estou souza
médico sanitarista mas que hoje eu estou
me aprofundando cada vez mais na área de
psiquiatria na área de saúde mental
o que eu tenho percebido tem observado e
já há várias pesquisas nesse sentido é
que esses meios de comunicação de
entretenimento estão trazendo problemas
à saúde das pessoas
eles possibilitam coisas boas é
favorecem coisas interessantes mas estão
trazendo problemas à saúde das pessoas
alguém poderá dizer mas será que tá
trazendo mesmo pode ser por outro motivo
e tal pesquisas bem feitas têm
conseguido separar a influência desses
meios de comunicação eu vou tentar
trazer alguns exemplos para vocês de
como isso pode afetar por exemplo fazer
perguntas rápidas assim como essa que a
gente fez pode tentar você poder
entender um pouco melhor
alguém que já foi acordado por um
aparelho de desse de comunicação no meio
do seu sono
todo mundo aqui praticamente respondeu
uma unanimidade né
alguém aqui já teve assim é é algum
momento de intimidade seu com alguém que
é importante para você
perturbado por um desses aparelhos de
comunicação em algum momento vários
momentos
alguns estão outros já não talvez por
que desliguem né
sabiamente o aparelho de comunicação
então o que está se discutindo hoje e
que algumas pessoas estão levantando
esse questionamento é que esses
aparelhos em determinados momentos
atrapalham a vida da gente a nossa nosso
relacionamento
algumas pessoas acham que esses
aparelhos de comunicação que
favoreceriam a comunicação entre a gente
em alguns momentos atrapalha essa
comunicação
teoricamente ele favoreceria a gente se
encontrar mais facilmente
falar mais facilmente um com os outros
mas na prática é o que a gente vem
observando é que muitas vezes esses
aparelhos por exemplo atrapalham a
relação dentro da família
muitas vezes um pai uma mãe tem muito
como já vinha fazendo isso é recorrente
e não é novidade aparece em seriados na
tv você já viu na sua casa é ele vem
críticas à tv é uma casa que está o pai
a mãe e dois filhos às vezes comendo
dentro de casa e os quatro estão se
comunicando com outras pessoas em outros
lugares em aparelhos em smartphones ou
coisa parecida
muito freqüentemente um filho está no
videogame dentro de casa tão entretido
que em consegue falar com ninguém
eu muitas vezes é eu tenho tirado me
limitado às horas de uso desse tipo de
equipamento para o meu filho mas muitas
vezes eu consegui uma participação com
ele tem que jogar com ele tem problema
jogo também não estamos aí para
participar junto mas então o que a gente
tem que estar discutindo e o cerne desse
debate mini debate que estou fazendo
aqui hoje é a tecnologia está cumprindo
a finura finalidade que você acha que
ela está fazendo na sua vida ela está
servindo para o objetivo que você teve
ao comprar essa tecnologia
ou você está sendo enganado é pura
tecnologia e obviamente que se entender
algumas coisas que você já sabe não
existe almoço de graça ou baixe o
aplicativo é grátis
não existe você sabe disso tudo o
aplicativo vem com uma propaganda nem
coco com um troca de dados então ele
pega o seu nome se vai votar alguma
coisa é baixar alguma coisa mudar alguma
coisa e meio quando você se cadastra
então nada é de graça não existe almoço
em pagar essa expressão já está virando
jargão mas é a verdade
então quando você está utilizando a
tecnologia a tecnologia está usando você
a questão é mas se você
é que a tecnologia silva ao seu
propósito
então pelo menos a troca pode estar
sendo um pouco justo né
ela pode estar sendo interessante só que
quando a gente começa a levantar o
número de crianças que cada vez mais
novas estão tendo crises de ansiedade
estão tendo crises de pânico quando a
gente começa a ver o número de pessoas
cada vez maior em pesquisas colocando
que usa maconha outras drogas porque
acalmam a cabeça porque não consegue um
momento de paz durante ver inúmeros
pessoas cada vez mais jovens com
problemas de insônia com problemas de
sono porque não consegue dormir direito
porque fica pensando em um aparelho
porque o aparelho apita porque ele
prefere ficar jogando até de madrugada
do que dormir e tudo mais
você começa a se questionar se aquela
tecnologia está trazendo benefícios para
você ou está trazendo malefícios pra
você e para sua saúde
então o que a gente quer discutir com
vocês aqui é fazer levantar um ponto de
interrogação na sua vida para você
coloca limites no uso da sua tecnologia
ou você deixa que a tecnologia usa e
você e você usa tecnologia de uma forma
que ao invés de ajudar você
ela está atrapalhando a sua vida está
fazendo com que a sua vida fique mais
complicado dentro da sua cabeça dentro
da sua família e até mesmo nos seus
relacionamentos
então esse questionamento que eu quero
estar trazendo pra vocês pra você pra
gente entender que a tecnologia deve
estar a nosso serviço
quando você adquire um equipamento que
você paga por ele você isso tem que
trazer um benefício para a sua vida para
os seus relacionamentos para as pessoas
que você quer se comunicar que as
pessoas que são importantes na sua vida
e não que essa tecnologia bloqueie essas
comunicações atrapalha as suas
comunicações e faça com que você tenha
problemas de saúde cada vez mais
recorrentes problemas de saúde mental
que todos nós estamos sujeitos
obviamente independente da tecnologia
mas o que ninguém está sentindo e
observando em pesquisas é que isso está
essa usa essa tecnologia de forma
desenfreada está trazendo danos para nós
então ou a reflexão que eu faço hoje com
vocês aqui é você que está conseguindo
usar a tecnologia de uma forma que ela
seja útil para você na comunicação mas
também que ela seja útil para você ela
ela ajude você a se transformar numa
pessoa melhor
a se transformar numa pessoa consegue
fazer os seus objetivos como pessoa você
reflete sobre isso porque se você não
reflete as empresas estão refletindo
porque todos os equipamentos como já
falei querem usar nos de alguma forma
estão se comunicando com nosco com algum
objetivo
querendo fazer com que a gente se
consuma alguma coisa ou querendo
conhecer a forma como a gente consome
pra poder induzir a compra de produtos a
compra de materiais a compra de serviços
às necessidades
há há há formas de nos tornarmos pessoas
diferentes
parece que o número de pessoas hoje
querem se exibir na rede é cada vez
maior necessidade da
mostrar então isso faz com que as coisas
é pó são está fugindo um pouco do
controle
a pergunta que eu vou deixar para vocês
no final das contas é nós estamos usando
a tecnologia ou a tecnologia está nos
usando uma reflexão que eu digo pra
vocês
é assim que eu volto a repetir toda a
tecnologia que a gente usa induz a gente
a fazer coisas que a gente queira quer a
gente não queira como vida gente a fazer
coisas que a gente não tinha pensado em
convidar gente a consumir coisas que a
gente não tinha imaginado e nós estamos
conscientes disso
nós estamos com essa clareza
estamos colocando limites no uso dessas
tecnologias
estamos educando os nossos filhos irmãos
pais sobre isso
estamos deixando que a nossa saúde
mental seja afetada por esses
equipamentos por esse uso dessa
tecnologia ou estamos usufruindo da
tecnologia para buscar conhecimento como
colega que falou em buscar comunicação
como a colega lhe falou buscar até
exibicionismo como amigo que falou então
fica esse questionamento que eu termino
mais uma vez com a pergunta você está
usando a tecnologia ou você está sendo
usado dessa tecnologia de comunicação de
massa
muito obrigado pela atenção de vocês
[Aplausos]